the business of growing up is something
we normally think comes to a close when
we get a 16 or so and finally turn into
those fully finished products adults up
until then our growth this subject of
quite a lot of collective fascination
20th century psychology beginning with
the work of the Swiss clinician Jean
Piaget pioneered an approach to child
development that meticulously identified
and labeled every principal stage an
average infant might go through on the
developmental journey of its earliest
years thanks to this work we now know
that it's six months a child will be
able to sit up on its own pick up a
small object such as raisin using a
thumb and forefinger and recognize its
own image in a mirror though it will
most likely take another three months
before it can drink from a cup on its
own and understand simple requests by
two it will start to say I and you and
it will probably be able to put on a hat
by itself around four one can expect it
to use sentences several words long and
quite possibly invent an imaginary
friend an achievement that belongs to
what Piaget called the symbolic function
substage between the ages of four and
seven children can begin to grasp
abstract concepts like time and a
country but typically make mistakes
around the use of less than and more
than parents uncles aunts and
grandparents tend to be deeply
interested in these developmental
milestones which become the stuff of
family legend
however after about 16 the attention
society pays to the maturation of an
individual becomes ever more coarsely
grained the focus shifts to external
material matters we track what someone
gets in their university degree what job
they secure and how they progress up the
corporate hierarchy growing up become
synonymous with getting ahead it in
truth we never stopped having
opportunities to grow in an emotional
rather than material or physical way
perhaps between the ages of 19 and 21
without anyone really focusing on this
happening we might radically rethink our
view of how to handle our parents
shortcomings or of you
envy can take a leap forward in the
middle of our 23rd year or as we
approach 33 lying in bed early one
morning in a hotel we might amend our
sense of who's to blame for certain
relationship difficulties we may look
more or less the same but inside slow
unheralded moments of emotional growth
can be going on unfortunately we have
nothing like the clear detailed stages
to measure ourselves against the babies
and young children enjoy and that might
give us the encouragement we'd need to
note and foster stages of growth yet
every adult life contains a potential to
acquire new emotional skills each in its
own way of significant as a child
mastering a quirk of language in English
for instance saying I thought rather
than I thinked or learning to ride a
bicycle to develop emotionally involves
a range of steps learning to understand
and sympathize with oneself to take
proper stock of one's childhood
influences to communicate flaws and
eccentricities to others in good time to
interpret others beyond what they have
directly said to us to recognize the
hard edges of reality without being
destroyed by them to accept one's need
for consolation and assistance to
achieve a necessary degree of confidence
to know how to despair without wholly
giving up on existence we can imagine
plotting this kind of inner journey like
Islands each one of them marked by
settlements which we should take the
trouble
systematically to go in the visit as we
might the cities of Renaissance Italy or
the beauty spots on the Pacific Highway
we tell our friends excitedly that we'd
learnt about emotional translation or
how to achieve excellent grades in
communication we might throw a party
when we'd reached
cheerful despair despite misleading
external signs we aren't ever in fact
done with a tricky business of becoming
that hugely important thing an
emotionally mature person or to put it
another simpler way a real grown-up we
love bringing you these films if you
want to help us to keep bringing you
thoughtful content please consider
supporting us by visiting our shop at
the link on your
scream now